moin moin freunde wie man hier in köln
sagt herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal meine stimme ist
ein bisschen angeschlagen bin ein wenig
erkältet allerdings
sonst heute nicht um eine erkältung
gehen sondern wir befinden uns vorne
nicht vor wien das wäre nicht so schön
allerdings vor allem rewe einem
supermarkt in köln meine damen und
herren was in diesem revier stattfindet
genauso wie in eigentlich jedem rewe in
deutschland bald auch gutes deutsch
meine damen und herren 15 18
heute ist meine pizza herauskommen die
pizza wird ist in diesem revier hier
wahrscheinlich auch eben deswegen würde
ich sagen die wir jetzt einfach mal rein
und bewegen uns ins tiefkühlregal bin
ich angekommen im revier noch nicht im
tiefkühlregal aber beide getränken
aber da müssen wir nicht hin
hey man fühlt sich ja so kommen
die leute das ist der grund warum wir
hier sind sondern
[Musik]
wie ein halb kaputt wieder hier
eigentlich die arbeit einer kita
wahnsinn
eigentum lokal muss eingestehen bitte
ein mitarbeiter behielten aber ich komme
morgen vergessen die handbremse drin
[Musik]
jakob ideen es werden jetzt die führung
wohl weniger
hier sind nur so 10 oder so kommen was
von den anderen alles lag schon respekt
da muss mehr rein das steht vom ihm die
pizza gemacht ist es geliebt und
tatsächlich ein wunderschönes exemplaren
das leckere ist natürlich in den
parteioberen freunde ich kacke die jetzt
natürlich nicht in diesem
rewe-supermarkt hier aus da liegt ein
bisschen zu wenig finde ich ein bisschen
zu wenig pizza in dem regal das mal
gucken ob irgendwo im lager so
vielleicht noch was finden will slomka
der liegen zehn pizzen von den andern
marken 400
das war
da das tür zum lager
müssen das bisschen besser planen
[Musik]
ich gehe da alleine rein wenn wir dazu
auch noch mit seiner kamera dann zeigen
wir direkt ein voll vogel wie machst du
das nimmst du handy mit stimmte also
leute die nächste szene ist die ich mit
dem handy in dem relativ knapp teilung g
& co kopfstützen finde natürlich auch
eine uniform oder sowas
[Musik]
ich bin drin
also sieht jetzt aus wie ein mitarbeiter
an dem wir mit automaten an dem werk
oder tomate nicht überall menschen
das mache ich hier zahnpasta
ich muss halt irgendeine uniform finden
oder sowas damit ich überhaupt erstmal
ein steve gehöriger rhein kann also da
wo quasi die pizzen aufbewahrt werden
irgend jemand irgendwas hier hängt eine
jacke dies wahrscheinlich und gegen
jemanden der gerade brauchen ist oder so
da steht drauf
let's go alter
und ein da kommen leute wieder
[Musik]
leute mir wird es hier ein bisschen zu
kritisch ich hole meine karre und
versuchten zu kriegen packt das handy
jetzt weg dann sehen wir uns hoffentlich
gleich bei twitter
so jetzt optisch schöner ausgleich schon
ne pizza gekauft also wirklich leute von
mir luca pizza zwei elektroschocker
wirklich meiner meinung nach hause so
leckere pizza dafür stehe ich mit meinem
namen muss natürlich jeder für sich
selbst entscheiden ob er die marke
berlin nicht mag aber leute jeder rewe
in deutschland hat diese pizza
allerdings eiskalt wie mein herz alles
klar auf jeden fall gibt diese pizza
heute ab dem 15 10 dem tiefkühlregal
wahrscheinlich nicht so geordnet
ich glaube ich bin der schlechteste
reber mitarbeiter der welt aber leute
kauft ihr euch gern testet sie gern die
findet auf den rückseiten verschiedene
polaroid bilder von mir zum beispiel mit
auch klasse untertiteln dann
aber noch nicht geschrieben ganz der
inhaltsstoffe freunde und die pizza ist
schwarz schwarzer tag das hat es noch
nie gegeben tiefkühlregal in deutschland
[Musik]
die sonne kann aber ich mache aber
besser als wichtigsten antrieb verkaufen
danke
der mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßen hallo noch ein verletzter
danach gibt der will ihn ja ich bin ja
mitarbeitern kommt mir ein bisschen
[Musik]
dass die leute jetzt kommt die kamera
angehalten das wegen seiner
[Musik]
da steht durchsage
also kein scheiß das hat sich jetzt echt
bisschen krass entwickelt es hier als
den sieg haben hat leute an und da wir
können ihr bezahlen ende so weit will
ich jetzt auch nicht jeder mit durchsage
drauf deswegen heute di luca fischer 2
wir müssten sie in die 5
schulungen für schulungen ja
[Musik]
machen sie das ich bin youtuber und
meine herausgekommen also das war für
sie hier werden haltung von spaß erlaubt
man kann sie also wir können das
manchmal bekommen
ja das war ganz ganz ganz witzig dann
kam tatsächlich dann noch der
ladendetektiv an und hat uns am ende wo
wir die jacke zurückbringen wollten hat
er uns auch angesprochen und wie es
weitergeht wenn ich euch jetzt aber
nicht sagen sondern meine damen und
herren wenn er einfach mal in die
beschreibung legte dort einen link und
lisa links würden euch zu einem video
von rewe und dort wird gesagt wie es
weitergeht werde ich wenn er verhaftet
ist zeit und freundliches gespräch
klickt auf den link da wird ihm dies
weiter geht die ganze story und wie in
diesem video bereits mehrmals gesagt
heute ist meine pizza rausgekommen eine
schwarze eine pizza prosciutto von mir
zusammen mit co star august um mega
lecker schaut sie euch einfach mal
probiert sion und der post gern bild
davon wird versucht durch zu lassen also
mich für diesen mega freundin ich weiß
nicht vielleicht hab ich sie sogar schon
gegessen ich habe mir mal eure meinung
ist wie pizza und in die kommentare und
dadurch dass wir hier gefallen hat
freunde das gerne mal einen like a day
wie jetzt auf jeden fall unserer spaß
gemacht
[Musik]